we have some incredible new video of our
friend donnie o'sullivan or do i never
remember if it's donnie or donio
sullivan he's a cnn reporter he's
excellent
he went to arizona over the weekend now
in arizona over the weekend there were
two different things going on one vice
pres former vice president mike pence
was campaigning for the challenger to
carry lake i forget the that candidate's
name
and uh donald trump was campaigning for
carrie lake
donio sullivan went
to arizona
interviewed the trump supporters
and it is as bad as anything that i have
ever seen let's take a look at it he
didn't lose
sensitive
he just didn't lose do you believe the
election was stolen
yes did you face in elections now
no
do you believe the 2020 election was was
stolen
uh no i don't believe the 2020 election
was stolen i believe that there are
aspects of the 2020 election that were
unfair in arizona a republican party at
odds with itself trump and pence holding
competing events with two very different
understandings of reality we need a
landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig it or
steal it even if they try at trump's
rally a bonfire of conspiracy theories
have you ever watched january 6 hearings
i have what do you think
i think they're a bunch of bull
boy
well because
do you have both sides or are you
getting one side of the story
you mean like the side that attacked the
capital
you really believe that happened
i was there okay
i have a lot of people that were there
guys she has people
and and saw things that it wasn't what
they say it was but there's been
hundreds of trump supporters now
charged
pled guilty so and do you think it's
right for those people to have those
people in jail and not get any justice
in our
american system all of a sudden you know
it's funny there's been no greater event
that has inspired the right to demand
criminal justice reform
uh pre-trial detention reform there's
been nothing it's been 40 years with the
left has been talking about this and all
of a sudden
these arguably domestic terrorists
are
arrested and jailed and now all of a
sudden the right is saying we're not
treating people in the justice system
very well incredible
do you think it was right that they
attacked the capital i don't they didn't
nobody attacked it guys it's all fake
the inside job buddy
the vast conspiracy theory that those
who stormed the capitol were not trump
supporters is widespread here have you
guys been watching the january 6
hearings at all no no
no we saw it when it all went down and
then we saw like a lot of the blm and
the antifa people in the building as
well it was antrifa well and and and
it's just it's just nonsense but i think
like 800 people now have been charged
twice oh yeah and number black lives
matter are antifa
so here's what happened
the real perpetrators of the january six
riots were black lives matter and antifa
in disguise as trump supporters
they have not actually been charged the
people that have been charged are the
real trump supporters who didn't do
anything but okay they're on video doing
stuff but they're actually black lives
matter
not really trump supporters but the
black lives matter people haven't been
charged and the ones charged are the
trump supporters who are victims
but it looks like they're on video doing
stuff but it's not really trump
supporters it's antifa you see how it's
just an endless circle this circle never
ends
it's like a mobius strip due process
because they have not been arrested
hunter biden hasn't been arrested trump
has told lies about the election and
that
he said he didn't really lose do you
think that all the lies about the
election are damaging for american
democracy
you believe he lied
do you not no i do not i don't why he
won but these are no longer fringe ideas
a majority of republicans do not believe
biden legitimacy won the election
hey guys any of you want to talk to us
the proud boys who trump once infamously
told to stand back and stand by now a
regular fixture outside his events any
pro boys want to talk to us today
no you've been watching january 6th
hearings
no nothing to say there's something
that's cnn right cnn yeah thank you my
friends okay thanks guys thank you
the former president here to campaign
for a ticket of conspiracy theory
spouting candidates who say they would
have overturned the results of the 2020
election in arizona like carrie lake
candidate for governor i know for a fact
we will no longer accept rigged
elections who's with me on that
right here campaigning for lakes
republican rival arizona needs karen
taylor robson in the state house here we
met some republicans who are done with
trump now here this is also interesting
because it's not like these are
reasonable people but they've had it
with trump
i voted for trump twice
if mike pence runs i'm voting for mike
pence okay so why is that i just think
that you know
everyone's seen the january six
committee uh
he stood up for democracy that day you
know he's like i'm not leaving the
capitol because
um i need to be here and he was the one
that was making phone calls through the
military yeah so this is fascinating
because i'm with you that compared to
the trump people this guy seems
eminently reasonable but remember pence
didn't really do anything pence didn't
have a choice
the thing that trump wanted pence to do
pence didn't have the power to do so now
they're considering pence a hero simply
because he didn't overtly try to do
something he had no right to do and that
seems reasonable by comparison
trying to fix the situation while trump
was crying in the dining room but even
among this crowd there is sympathy for
trump's election lies and support for a
2024 run you're about to see pence speak
here
trump's not a big fan of him right now i
understand that
i hear that he could have not certified
those results pending all the claims of
the fraud and i wish he would have done
that pence had no legal basis to do that
also among those here rusty bowers a
lifelong republican and speaker of the
arizona state house
we're talking to a lot of people in here
today who said they're not even
they're not watching the january 6th
hearings they still believe
about the 2020 election how do you what
would be your message to them
i i have no message for him i can't help
him if you don't want to look you don't
want to see then you won't see
but
i've seen enough to know
and i know that all the people right in
this room have done their best to count
everything and do it all right he
testified before the january 6 committee
about trump's efforts to get him to
overturn the 2020 results in his state
what is these conspiracy theories these
lies
about the election about democracy what
is that doing to trust
in this state it destroys it it destroys
it we've got to let things go what would
need to change for you to have face
in us democracy
i don't trust our government first of
all period and if you don't have fair
elections what good are they do you ever
worry that you're wrong do you ever
worry that oh absolutely
you ever worry that maybe trump has sold
you a lie if you start researching and
believe that you're the one who's wrong
and that you're crazy which i did do
thinking okay maybe i'm wrong and maybe
i am being brainwashed and believing
something that someone's telling me but
then you go in and look the other
direction and you find lies after lies
after lies right she suspected she was
being lied to but then she's like the
other side is lying even more i guess so
this is
these are very resistant to change
beliefs
and there is going to be a real battle
for the republican party if you look at
the polling you already see it and we're
going to look at some of that polling
later this week probably or maybe next
week um this is going to be a real
battle in not only 22 but in particular
in 2024 but look at the folks that are
being fought over and that really should
make us think wow
this is not exactly a group to put it
politely
that is necessarily going to fairly and
soberly and calmly
evaluate the claims being my being made
by the trump and anti-trump sides of the
republican party and come to some kind
of empirical conclusion
uh and that should scare all of us we're
going to continue covering these types
of interview interviews really really
good job there by donio sullivan
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chile sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and ten
percent off the new dock pro this offer
is only for my audience the link is down
below